>> Of the issues you care about
I've been city.
>> We continue here on the guy
Benson show. You're just
mentioning, New York and Texas.
Let's go ahead and talk about
Florida as well.
Because I think we all know
that Florida has been in the
spotlight, politically
because the governor of Florida
is seen as a political threat.
Hence
the relentless program and
project a demonization of Ron
DeSantis that we have covered
and chronicled and reacted to
and fact check on this show
over and over again. There's a
new one out there that
we'll get you here in just a
second, but first I want to
draw your attention to a new
poll out of Florida. This is
from USA Today and Suffolk.
And they asked Florida voters
about the upcoming midterm
elections. And let's just say
that things aren't looking
great. For the Democrats in the
state of Florida.
President Joe Biden has a 39%
approval rating in Florida
which is about right. Bush in a
few national polls having.
Biden at 39% or sell in Florida
is a large diverse
swing state. So would make
sense that his job approval
would be roughly as bad there
may be a little worse than it
is nationally.
Biden's personal favor
ability rating is under water
by 11 points. In the state of
Florida. So what about some
head to heads looking
at 2022 this election cycle
first of all in the Senate
side. Marco Rubio is up for
reelection this year.
Woman named Val Demings up
against him.
And right now Rubio is ahead by
8 points. In that race.
4941, maybe they'll tighten
this thing's going to ebb and
flow. But Rubio is a very heavy
favorite to win reelection
being up by 8.
In Florida is a pretty
significant deal. Now on the
governor's side.
You've got a few Democrats who
would like to be the nominee
against governor DeSantis.
You have Charlie Crist who's
the former governor member of
Congress, he ran for Senate and
failed he is this shape shifter
who believes nothing. He has
run for statewide office in
Florida as a Republican.
As an independent. And as a
Democrat.
And I think for this race, he's
got his magic 8 ball and he
shook it up what am I going to
be today and it's Democrat.
She got Charlie Crist means.
Believes absolutely nothing.
>> Imagine believing so little.
That you run for
statewide office
under 3 different party labels
depending on what you think
your personal ambition might be
helped by at any given moment.
It's actually
almost impressive. In terms
of its sheer cynicism and
selfishness. And he's probably
to get.
Gerrymander a redistricting out
of existence in his House seat.
He's currently Democrats and I
can run for governor.
He trails DeSantis by 6 points.
In this poll. Then you've got
Nikki fried who is the
current agriculture secretary,
but she's just sort of like one
of these twitter trolls she's
the one who recently compared.
Ron DeSantis to Hitler. Said
DeSantis reminds her a lot of
Hitler.
Maybe she and Whoopi Goldberg
can go to remedial history
class together something.
But that's what she said she
supposedly like the leading
serious candidate on the
Democrat side. She believes
every conspiracy theory she
amplifies every nonsense attack
on Ron DeSantis even stuff that
gets instantly debunked.
She was a hype woman for that
crazy person. Rebecca Jones.
Right the career criminal who's
been out there lying constantly
about Florida,
manipulating the data it's all
untrue. It's all been debunked.
But because it was being used
as a weapon against DeSantis
Nikki fried recklessly
amplified all of it.
I don't know if she ever does
her day job she ever done
anything about agriculture in
Florida seems like all she does
is sit on twitter.
And lob insults at Ron DeSantis
how's that going for her.
In this poll it's DeSantis 51
Nikki fried 40 DeSantis up 11.
Ron
DeSantis is the only statewide
or national figure in the state
of Florida. That in
this poll is above 50%
unfavorability rating. He's
plus 1050 to 42.
And as I said he leads his
would be Democratic opponents
by a range of 6 to 11 points.
So I tell you this not
because it's dispositive not
because polling at this stage
really matters a lot. Although
we are in the election year.
But these are not good sign for
the Democrats I read you these
polling numbers, mostly
just in case there are any
members of the media listening.
Because I'd like to give them a
sad.
Because they have tried so hard
I know you guys have tried so
hard against Iran.
I know it has to be really
really sad to see the people of
Florida, not falling for it
sorry.
But that's what's happening so
far and it brings me great joy.
Even as someone who is not
necessarily. In every way shape
or form.
A giant Ron DeSantis Stan,
I like him I think he's done a
good job I mostly talk about it
because of the insane attacks
against him. And we'll get to
another one here as I've now
teased in just a moment.
I do want to say this one
thing. Before we move on from
the USA Today poll out of
Florida. Which as I
mentioned as Biden 39%
approval.
He's a 36% approval on the
economy.
So it's it's not going. Well in
fact. It's so ugly
out there that they did a
hypothetical poll in this
survey of Democrats.
If there were looking ahead to
2024 a primary where Hillary
Clinton. We brought back
crooked H.
And they had her run for the
nomination and there was a
primary in Florida.
Crooked H would be Joe Biden by
3 points in a Democratic
primary for president right
now. Based on
this survey. That's how bad it
is out there.
Our
esteemed president, there's
another 2024 Paul that's
interesting. They polled
what if in Florida these are
Florida voters what if Donald
Trump ran again
and Ron DeSantis also ran and
they were going head to head
which one would you prefer be
the Republican nominee for
president and it's pretty
close. Trump is ahead by
single digits. But DeSantis
is is hang in right there.
And of course he needs to
get reelected first, but he
could maybe build toward
something bigger. In the state
of Florida. I also find the
head to head less interesting
than this. And this is the last
data point that I'll share with
you from the pole.
They asked Florida voters again
the largest most diverse swing
state in the country.
If in 2024, there was a
presidential election and it
was Joe Biden on the ballot for
the Democrats. Head to head
against Ron DeSantis or head to
head against Donald Trump who
do you vote for. In a rematch.
Twenty-twenty rematch.
In 2024. Trump
versus Biden Trump leads Biden
by 3 points 47 to
44% in Florida right now.
Ron DeSantis leads Biden by
8 points
52 to 44. Percent right now.
Long way to go very early
stages, but I do think that
Republican voters need to think
about viability. In 2024.
If Trump decides to run or if
he's thinking about running is
he the best person to actually
have a chance to win. I think
Republicans have a chance to
win big. Potentially in 2024.
I think the candidate that
would give them the best chance
to do that is to
Republican voters ought to be
considering that's a key
calculation moving forward.
Now it's clear that the
Democrats in the media view
DeSantis as a threat not just
in 2022.
They're going to try to beat
him this year but based on this
and other surveys. It's going
to be heavy lift.
That's not guarantee that he's
going to win reelection
DeSantis but you know. He's in
the driver's seat at this
point.
What they are really scared
about is the presidential
cycle. If this guy can win,
especially the winds kind of
big in the state of Florida.
Any racks up a bunch of
victories and he's the type of
candidate that can bring in
an appeal to Trump the
Republicans in moderately Trump
the Republicans and Trump
skeptical Republicans if he can
sort of coalesce everyone
that's something that. They're
worried about and they are not
telling us that with their
words they're telling us that
with their actions.
After smear after lie about Ron
DeSantis from the media and the
Democrats working as a team as
they so often do
to me it is very telling part
of the reason that I have grown
fonder of Ron DeSantis I don't
think I've ever even that.
Is because of the way they
attacked him they attack him
and continue to the fun fear
is palpable they are trying to
take him out and they're doing
it with
such silliness and baseless
Nissen hysteria that it is
caught my attention obviously
which is why we talk about it a
lot here on the show.
Performance in
terms of you know governance.
You could cite for example
keeping Florida schools open
last year big decision
governance is a feather in Ron
DeSantis is cap right now.
I would say that if he's able
to pull it out. Let's say he
has a convincing victory in
Florida. The crucial state that
would be another feather in his
cap. Especially these weathered
the storm.
Of all of these attacks and
then the attacks themselves
from the left and from the
press. And the way that he's
responded to them. That to me
is another big plus.
You know sort of in the in the.
Positive versus negative COLUMN
when assessing Ron DeSantis as
a political actor.
Now here's the latest thing
that they're going to try to do
with him. Apparently it's it's
so.
Apparently there was a
group of like neo-nazi a whole
racists. 11 of them or
something.
And they went on some overpass
in Florida I think somewhere in
central Florida. They're
waiting they're not see flags
can you imagine being such a
loser. That you wave the flag.
Of a defeated.
Disgraced genocidal regime like
these are just extremely
pathetic people. Representing
a disgusting meteorologist and
there's 11 of them for a
reason.
Way out there on the friend so
they were doing some.
Hateful nonsense on an
overpass.
There I Flyers have been
distributed at some point and
people were obviously
incorrectly upset about Nazis
doing not see things
because I think almost everyone
can agree Nazis sort of
along with like hard-core
should be sure the opinions of
evil that inflicted. Missouri
on humanity and killed millions
of people it's just awful doing
anything in the name of that
type of regime to me is.
And also sort
of baffling it just like very
sad loser people who are
engaged in this stuff.
This became a scandal
because it happened in Florida
why isn't Ron DeSantis out
there denouncing this.
So that became the drum beat
Ron DeSantis won't denounce
Nazis.
I don't think even Nikki fried
even though she compares him to
Hitler don't think even Nikki
fried believes that Ron
DeSantis is interested in like
winking at Nazis, but this is
how desperate they are so
that's what they said.
That's been one of the
narratives and it's been all
over you know hash tagging in
left wing twitter in that whole
echo chamber and so just to
give you a sense of how
mainstream this nonsense has
gotten Steven Kolb air who runs
his nightly. Group therapy for
liberals on CBS.
On his so-called comedy show
last night. He was talking
about this and he made this
point in cut 15. Speaking of
the worst people in public
office.
>> Florida governor man
describing what adele's music
means to him.
Ron DeSantis over the
weekend horrifically there are
a couple of not see rallies in
Orlando. I assume they were
trying to annex the sudetenland
Pavilion at Epcot.
This is terrible and the
easiest thing in the world to
condemn unless you're Ron
DeSantis who remain silent.
>> So he mentions DeSantis in
the New York liberal crowded
there. Therapy session they all
blew together bad boo and then
what cold air alleges is that
there's been these not see
rallies in Florida and
desantis's silent won't say
anything that was yesterday on
cold air show problem for cold
air is not only is this not
comedy and not funny
and totally in separate it's
also factually wrong because
the day before on Monday.
DeSantis had condemned these
people he called them, Jack is.
He said they be held
accountable. He also said he
wouldn't play along with the
stupid left wing game. This
answer is part of the reason
why I think that he's a
skilled politician and popular
on the right here was DeSantis
the day before not being silent
about this so fact check
therefore called bear on his
comedy show cut 16. This was
Monday governor DeSantis
these people.
>> These Democrats who are
trying to use this to some type
of political issue to try to
smear me as if I had something
to do that we're not playing
their game. You know some Jack
is you know doing this on the
street first of all state law
enforcement is going hold them
accountable because they were
doing stuff on the overpass so
we're so they're absolutely
going to do that and they
should do that. But I'm not
going to have
people try to smear me that
belong to a political party,
that is elevated anti-semites
to the halls of Congress like
Dylan Omar that have played
footsie with the bds movement
that even have people in their
party that if cavorted with
Farrah Khan.
>> Yeah, it's like OK guys in
your glass houses on anti
Semitism on the left are you
kidding, you're going to try to
bootstrap this into an issue or
it's totally nonexistent.
They were doing I guess stuff
that was it legal up they're
going to be held accountable
there. Jack is
then he goes through not just
talking about the problems on
the left of anti Semitism.
Then he reflect then he
reflected on and contrasted
that with his own record.
Combating antisemitism in the
state of Florida. Point after
point after point. And he
concluded with this quote
so they tried to play games
talking about the Democrats to
try to politicize why would
they do that
why would they want to elevate
half a dozen malcontents and
try to make this an issue for
political gain. Very good
question. I think we all know
why it's gross. He responded to
it well.
Why would you elevate
these people if not to try to
pretend that there was a not
see related controversy
involving a governor that you
hate and you're scared of.
That's your answer right there.
And it's not
just some weirdos on twitter in
Florida.
It's comedy hosts on national
television.
Who are not only an funny in
this circumstance. But just
flat wrong which is lazy to
boot. They keep coming after
him. He keeps responding.
He knows how to fight back and
that's part of the reason why
they fear him and why we keep
seeing this type of garbage
flowing in his direction batted
away pretty effortlessly again